sometimes productivity can be self-care
what's what's going on with that so I
think that's one of the main triggers
for the book was actually the fact that
like people would be like oh self-care
relax and
of care is meeting that deadline that
you're currently not on track to meet
but actually respecting your future self
and your goals we cannot Market
self-care as always like doing nothing
sometimes self-care is working harder
because you're currently not working in
line with what you want to make happen
and I think that again the internet
hates that because it doesn't fit into
this idea of like well-being versus
productivity a lot of the stuff in the
book is around how to know at what point
something will be self-care versus
self-sabotage or any of these things to
create a life that revolves around your
boundaries and where you need to be more
productive and where you probably need
to stop being so harsh on yourself